[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
my mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at 8:00
p.m. makes you a better mom support
herself a glass and let's talk I'm super
into these little personal sized bottles
lately especially of bubbly this is
Prosecco and usually when you open a
whole bottle you kind of need to finish
it because the bubbles go away and then
it's gross but not when you have these
little fools I don't think these have a
cork I got to use a blanket for this oh
hey there's a topic that's been running
pretty rampant on Facebook and I don't
understand why it's so controversial
we're gonna talk about it's night so
let's discuss the worst parts about
breastfeeding fair warning I am Pro
breastfeeding so if you don't like it
you've been warned you don't have to
watch this you can close it and go on
with your day and not leave a crappy
comment Thanks so first judgy people I
don't understand why other people who
either don't have children at all or
don't breastfeed involve themselves in
this breastfeeding debate like for
example this guy that I'm friends with
on Facebook who doesn't have any
children posted his status that said
just saw a mom nursing on the subway too
much I think so
and I saw that and I was like all right
mommy time first of all that mom is
nursing her child on the subway for the
benefit of everyone around her so they
don't have to deal with a shrieking
Banshee for the entire subway ride
second a mom can't determine one of her
child is going to be hungry I would like
to see you try reasoning with a newborn
no now is not the time that you're
allowed to eat you're gonna have to wait
till moms at home alone in privacy good
luck
also people act as if women go to
breastfeed their kids and are just like
breastfeeding time everyone's husband
gather round time for the boobie Shelly
no the goal is not to give someone a
free show and the amount of breasts that
actually shows is like a bikini so if
your cool way to the beach and not going
up to women
how indecent of you leave the
breastfeeding mom alone the whole point
of breasts are to feed children and if
you can't separate what the breasts
actual function is from what you would
like them to be maybe you shouldn't be
in public at all I can't believe that
this is even a thing that people get mad
about and rant it's hard to drink this
quickly that's my only issue next be
ever changing girls I would buy bras and
one hour they would fit and then the
next hour they'd be too small and then
the next hour they'd be too big and then
the next hour they would fit again
they're changing in size every hour
based on how much militaries and then
when they're to fall they just pour milk
everywhere I can't even tell you how
many times I was having a conversation
with a person and their eyes just slowly
went like and it's because my shirt was
soaked like I have two big wet balls
come on like I would get to the point of
just like shoving paper towels in there
I was like a high schooler again just
like stuff in my raw paper towels
nothing to see here don't touch them
because it'll crinkle I'm really
grateful to be past the whole
breastfeeding phase because now my
breasts can go back to the way that they
once were which apparently is nothing
cheers to what they once were
next pumping if you ever were wondering
what the life is like as a dairy cow
have a baby in pump after all the
advances in technology you'd think that
these pumps would be a little bit quiet
why are the pumps still so goddamn loud
one time they're camping so I'm trying
to discreetly pump in our tent and
everybody's like hey hey she drilling
something in there what is she huh hey
they have these cups that go over and
they're like these little cones that you
stick over and they're like yank your
boobs in and out I made the biggest
mistake of looking at myself in the
mirror while I was pumping once Oh
pretty must the thirst is real with both
of my kids the weirdest thing happened
every time I went to nurse them and they
latched I would just get like beyond
thirsty like desertedisland haven't had
water in three days thirsty
I never had the thought to be like oh I
should probably get some water and like
leave it near me for when I'm nursing or
once your kid latches it's like game
over you're stuck for a good half an
hour so I try to signal my husband like
and I'm pretty sure it's a reflex
that your body has to make sure that
you're hydrating while you're nursing
because making breast milk takes so much
water so if this has happened to you
please leave it in the comments because
I'm super confused about it to this day
and I wanted them not alone oh the last
the end when it's time to wean your
child it is a bundle of mixed emotions
you're happy to have your boobs back
you're sad because then your child is
not depending on you anymore my first
child nursed forever and it got to a
point where I had to say you're eating
like three adult sized meals a day it's
time and then with my youngest he was
exclusively breastfed until he was eight
months old and then I got a full-time
job and I just had to quit cold-turkey
because being a working mom is really
tough and then trying to pump on top of
it is even tougher I was the one who
suffered more from that because I just
felt so badly about it he didn't really
care he was like Oh milks in a bottle
today alright after both of those
experiences I realized that no matter
how my baby is getting fat as long as
he's being fed that's good and I'm doing
a good job and for any moms out there
who are struggling with breastfeeding or
who have had to stop breastfeeding or
who couldn't from the start you're doing
fine too but if you're a person who's
been a judge a mother for nursing just
know that she is not doing it for
anything besides the sole purpose of
benefiting her child so either give her
a high five or walk on by
so that's all I got for today I'm Kanna
your friendly neighborhood wine mom and
if you've had any experience
breastfeeding or lack thereof leave it
in the comments because this couch this
is a safe place I want to hear about
everyone's experience and I don't want
anybody to feel judged and I'm gonna
enjoy the rest of my little personal
bottles while I still can because I
while I still can oh that sounds like
I'm getting I'm not kidding pregnant
Tom Kevin don't give me that look
Kevin's behind the camera like not
having any babies soon so I'm going to
finish my little cute bottle of
champagne because I can because I earned
it and this one is for all of you women
breastfeeding out there and all of you
pregnant women out there cuz I know a
lot of pregnant women watch this and
this one's for you and as soon as you
pop that baby out come over and have a
glass with me until next time
ah please include that so everyone knows
how pretty I am
[Music]